[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ça va je crois qu'après la mort des
sanctions
qu'est ce tu fais tu
je dîne avec nous ah oui et après dîner
tu as fait quelque chose au prévenu a
rien de prévu
parce que nous on va passer peut-être
plaza et puis après quoi les barques ou
matisse est d'accord
mais réussit à je sais que je joue
en scène soignée
[Musique]
oui et bien qu'à cuba qui sert au
quatrième étage
o o
[Musique]
du thé chap
c'est très mignonne j'aime beaucoup
d'ennemis
attention
à
[Musique]
wouah soir ça va
jean pierre et michèle saint marc ils
sont pas là du tout elles sont arrivées
non je suis désolé ne sont pas l'arrivée
ça va super c'est génial tout en nuances
quelle copine mignonat c'est génial on
verra s'ils ont chaud dit bonjour et un
jour là
et à l'heure après leur passage avec
nouba inverse s'apprête dans le
cinquième jeu tu veux dire que tu veux
laisser tab est là je vais laisser
peut-être ma veste mais l'étoile a
devrait bien alors mal à garder cela
c'est bien sinon super dis moi comment
ça se passe avec mocky bah ça se passe
bien toujours la folie la passion d'un
âge larcher un tournage sur tournage et
là on est en plein tournage du nouveau
film
touristes touristes wyeth il ya combien
de temps que vient d'avoir une coupe de
champagne et combien il ya combien de
temps que tu es j'avais plus et ben on
fait ça fait cinq ans que chez deux fois
deux petites fois mais je crois qu'on ne
pouvait pas vivre l'un sans l'autre
alors tu vois quoi moi je bois pas
d'alcool
quant à nicole pas du tout à du jus de
fruits exotiques mois le petit peu de
champagne
voilà oui tu l'a connu en 85 dont 185 le
tournage la machine à les coudes
ouais et tu ne supportes way back
quelquefois il est difficile à vivre
oui mais je crois que j'arrive quand
même et il ya quand même le sentiment
avoué je crois qu'il est capable vous
êtes d'être amoureuse un musée mais il
est très très dur
et enfin il est difficile parfois les
capricieux voilà il dit partout qui
s'est appelée six cents 600 femmes comme
ça j'aime pas un nom que je sais qu'il a
commencé très jeune talent il a été
marié à 14 ans mais il a commencé très
jeune je crois qu'il s'est fait des
puces l'âge de trois noms de tir d'un
truc que je suis il ya olivier ardisson
partition il est là à croire mais oui a
pas d'art fois j'avais interviewé et il
m'avait dit jeudi mais alors tu tiens
avec le nombre de grossesses que tu as
eue doit être une affaire de la fin de
super coup d'état est en fait il m'a dit
au niveau de la taille c'est plutôt bien
mais c'est pas énorme mais en revanche
je suis assez pervers que je crois qu il
l'apport au quatrième étage savages
choix je crois que c'est du lait mais
voilà bon alors on va trouver celui non
mais dis moi avant qu'ils arrivent de la
valeur avait fait perdre leur nom ces
îles et les romantiques avec moi je
racontais l'a été avec les autres serge
était pas là pour le voir mais avec moi
il est c'est un petit hameau j'adore on
a on a des petits câlins du tendre il
est lisse fait pas dresser le pain qui
non non non ils n'acceptent pas d'être
dominé par une femme ça c'est ça le but
mais mais il est il peut être tendre six
ans qu'il était mais quand il sent qu'on
l'ait 1000 et du jeune j'avais quand
même différente raconte paola on a 30
ans des mois jekel je vais avoir 40 ans
de woodstock et oui il a un à 70 bah ça
fait rien ah bon ouais parce qu'il est
resté jeune de la ligue déjà deux fois
je vois qu'à l'appartement ils ont une
nouvelle en carafe
ah non
bonjour tu vas bien dit dans ses rangs
mais j'aime ça mais ça va on essaie de
tournage des filets oui ça va bien
disons oui voilà c'est pour toi ça je
crois du courrier dans la famille mieux
ensemble à un regard honnête je suis le
seul ça va on va dîner michel moi j'ai
présenté ma nouvelle copine la main
ah bon allez dis bonjour à michel
serrault via bonjour est ce que tu veux
et ce que tu aimes michel serrault oui
sourit aussi est ce que tu sais sourire
fait un beau sourire a tenté -en michel
g skill dit toi il y ce que j'aime chez
michel serrault c'est qu'ils acceptent
de faire tous mes films pour pas un rond
et ça je trouve ça sympa oui parce que
le danger d'entrée très bien la gestion
interne au nom des liens puissants
mission blagueur et ce sans blague
oui la cuisine parce que moi je suis
arrivée là on va dire tu aimes les
couleurs à toi ouais j'aime la couleur
j'aime les couleurs assez tôt la chaîne
d'arriver absurde
asseyez-vous tu donnes l'étoile à
jean-pierre salon existe la médiature
prendre la place verte et vous noterez
until lui nous tous les signé ouais
alors voilà blanc donc c'est carlos qui
ont fait des bonds de carlos michel bon
alors je n'ai pas dit il mais rien de
particulier dans l'est
pl mais simplement se confesser des
dîners à thème donc la semaine dernière
c'était un dîner orange
oui ce soir c'est nenê rosa explique
tout ce que tu mets dans valero voilà
les ballets roses exactement cher de
toto au corps les fruits pas mal jus de
truffe à l'abs
moi ça va a fait procéder ce qu'on pense
c'est à dire que comment ça se passe on
est invités ou drake invités on peut
participer comme cette grande info il
vaut mieux penser à la vitesse
tu vois quoi moi jai ho de l'eau dans le
panneau en oeuvre d'un jeu un peu d'eau
parce que tu sais que tu en as et que je
suis aujourd'hui je me suis levé à cette
heure je sers j'ai fait d un peu de
synchro j'ai vu un autre film que je
vais boire etc
et là je suis là et demain matin je me
lève à 7h c'est que si tu te comportes
si tu veux continuer à manger une
normalement simplement sans gagner de la
promo de deux minutes ch il adore
c'est en ce moment pendant qu'on va le
regarder c'est trop triste
il vaut mieux regarder le film de kung a
fait un long de regarder à quoi ça
ressemble et jézabel comment le furet le
furet et joue le rôle il est formidable
parce qu elle qui l'a pas la même tête
qui doit domizzi bien entendu et pas la
même tête que dans le papillon est pas
la même tête que dans les rondelles il
s'est fait la tête des acteurs que nous
adorons tous les deux jeunes berryman
mais c'est le grand acteur mais avec le
costume je dirais d'un costume de grand
acteur alors qu'est ce qui se passe
vivre et comment il va vivre il m'a très
bien d'ailleurs il est coproducteur de
films ce qui est rare dans le temps
c'était bon rythme qui était co
producteurs viennent et le nom lui est
c'est ce héros par leur présence déjà on
n'est pas mal quand tu vas vivre assez
haut dans un film et puis après j'ai
renucci patricia dick rivers karl zéro
alors que lui est pas grave ils jouent
un rôle un peu à la marron brando à
notre eu un vieux truand il est
formidable la première minute fait
tomber par terre de bons sièges de rire
parce que je sais pas possible de voir
un acteur en parlant de moi qu'ils en
fassent autant
mais autant dans l'inspiration divine
jules berry michel simon raimu lisant
faisait et aujourd'hui les acteurs
doivent exister autrement que des
cloches comme ça des types et que ton
place mi scappa smic et qui a dans le
cinéma français
il ya la nature bougies lui c'est l'art
c'est la relève de plein de gens de
saturnin de même de beaux vide et de
michel six mois il est il est toujours
en même temps c'est formidable quand
elle commence et a commencé avec ces
mecs là oui et justement je laisse aux
crêtets dérivant le shrine mais le jules
berry donc quand j'étais môme je ne
berry n'avait pas un rond et jouer aux
courses je crois il est aidé dans son
fauteuil à l'elysée matignon
il avait perdu toute sa vie on l'avait
jetée d'hollywood s'était des types
extraordinaire il touché et très peu
d'argent d'ailleurs il faisait des
cachetons on va bien on va bien
t'énerver soit parce que donc yaya
l'abbé de la morandais donc qu'un tueur
r je crois que vous le dire même si le
saint curé spectacle c'est comme un
chêne cyril et
ils étaient les cinq clowns 6/5
circulant dans l'autre la le monseigneur
gaillot ou mes débuts je veux dire
d'abord google est bien c'est que
l'amour en dépit d'une vieille famille
d'extrême droite machin quand il était
en algérie il s'est battu contre la
torture
c'est ça c'est une vraie était mal vu
c'était mal vu mais il a été un peu
comme pâris de la bollardière tu vois il
fait partie de ces mecs qui en algérie
au mondial la france peut pas nommer les
biens alors longtemps fait pas un
ensemble ils n'apprécient pas prononcé
sur le film corse
ouais bah voila mon père khairy voilà
mon bouquet de fleurs merci mon père
bonsoir ça va on est tous à la cuisine
ouais et on parlait de vous voilà je
disais bien que vous gilles le père de
la morandais la rencontre s qui boit de
l'alcool ce qu'il boit de l'alcool
je sais pas je te faire pardonner toutes
tes péchés
bien entendu sûrement pas repêchés sains
renée paré cinq sens bénie avec ce
projet il faut le mal est fait la
cuisine alors assigné gauche présente
dans le conte dont qui alors qu'il vient
de faire un bouquin si vous venez faire
un bouquin sur le pape
sauf qu'en avril ce soit est tombé dans
un piège a changé bonjour toi qualité
chacun a été incroyable est tombé dans
un piège c'est sûr mais kurt on peut
toujours tout donné a mentionné michel
zendali plein d'amitié
oui oui vous savez l'histoire fait que
toi quand tu étais petit tu voulais être
prêtre ou clown il a été maintenant son
rêve c'est de revenir j'en rêve c'est de
devenir moine donc jouer un rôle de fret
re ah oui ça serait bien où on avait
parlé vous devez vous taire ça a été dit
en confession non un truc que je
comprends pas c'est quand tu fais de
mitchie tu dis je veux bien jouer deux
minutes chi à condition qu'ils 2 2 qui
soit non coupable et quand tu es petit
tu sais bien que c'est un assassin
pourquoi eh bien tu veux que je te
raconte brièvement parce que je suis
pour rien pour faire des conférences
c'est vrai qu'on me reprochait dans
l'exemple de jouer voiture me disais
mais où le jus samedi que sympathique
sympathique mais je dis vous êtes alors
le géant entre parenthèses mais quand
même il faut dire les mots vous êtes des
cons les gens qui me posait la question
du bien on se rappelle qu'il y avait une
vieille dame jusqu'au bout de tous
pouvaient brumeux recevoir mon mari et
en amérique du sud le rugby j'ai pu
beaucoup de temps et qui doit entrer
maintenant
autre et bada bon mais cela dit je pense
bête j'ai montré ce qu'est et puis alors
ce qui est plus grave parce que je peux
quand même me défendre je joue vraiment
petit c'est vrai mais je raconte une
fois vous qui me parler ou ce que vous
étiez pendant la guerre alors vous dire
bah moi je t'ai fait de la résistance
également avec café distance ça se
trouve ça toujours et l'autre là qui dit
ben oui j'ai pas fait de la résistance
vous étiez quoi vous et y avait plus tôt
pour les allemandes aux effets de la
vous avez collaboré vous ne fait que non
pas vraiment mais bon c'est fait rabbo
et puis l'on tait vous dit les bains et
moi qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous là
pendant la guerre
pendant que toi tu roules vu en vrai
avec sa chaudière et ben moi gt gt1 moi
j'ai rien fait gt gt gt je tenais un
cabaret à à pigalle et qui avait comme
le client il faut dire dieu mais des
résistants des démobilisés dans
resistance faut dire qu'il y avait des
allemands qui fait la moue ce qui il
faut dire aussi qu'il veut des courses
aussi vous dire quoi
et il avait un tas de gens de 21 et bien
je dis bravo
je vous remercie maintenant c'est une
raison de plus pour jouer et si peu tout
à exister c'est vous vous avez été
complice car chaque fois que j'avais un
problème de droite de gauche du centre
du ciel ou d'en bas il en docteur est ce
qu on pourrait vous amener un paquet ce
soir alors basta
eh bien c'était vous a convaincu de
l'innocence alors dookie d'amitié j'ai
préco n'y a aucune preuve contre lui
à partir du moment me suis pas juriste à
partir du moment où vous dit il n'y a
pas de preuve pour l'un pour le condamné
et il est innocent d'abord et en plus il
se trouve que je connais bien les gens
de la terre et les paysans ah voilà
alors basta aussi me raconte pas
d'histoires c'est pas parce que on n'est
pas très fidèle avec sa bonne femme et
qu'on est dur avec ses enfants et qu on
a 12 hectares et compte pendant des 75
ans on travaille pour avoir des prunes
et projets en cours sur ces darmon est
en train de se garer orchis gorge
non mais toujours bon c'est pas c'est
pas suffisant
pourquoi j'étais rude il n'était pas
facile il n'était pas très instructive
et pas bête il n'était pas comme chief
il était comme moi j'espère oui c'est un
film haratine est un peu c'est vrai à
passer à table un vip le salut des
champions ça fera rêver d'un montant
important verts ont pourtant bien
dommage non mais c'est vous êtes très
bien mais vous allez retourner
j'étais bien
l'aca
c'est une belle dame pour le 15
[Musique]
je suis
à
michel ont fait bénéficier des premières
chères estime entre chalais même moqué
m
le père du fils et du saint-esprit amène
bénédicte noie ses textos à donna
persique où l'on sait que le ramène trop
me direct amer et et kato toi donc j'ai
été baptisé par la gare ont été baptisés
n'ont jamais été si recommencer mais
baptisé heureusement sinon ce n était
pas tout si toi non ces enrichissements
michel on lui a pas expliqué c'est un
dîner prosélyte au cours duquel on a
décidé qu'on n'ait à table mais il
manque des ménages est en effet arrivé
non ses jambes armand irène jacob en
tant que production qui leur arrive et
il m'a était en train de se garer il m'a
dit le voile vous êtes pour le voit est
ce que c'est pour le voile non mais moi
je vous est ce qu'on le voit l'écouté
moi quand j'étais jeune j'allais au à
l'école avec un chapeau mou de joueurs
88 on n'a jamais viré lordon jeu pour le
savez la chaude
[Applaudissements]
vous avez entendu vous avez l'impression
soir là on n'a rien apporté
c'est pas grave vous êtes là très
contente si on ajoute avoir des singes
pas pourquoi ne vous demande pas
pourquoi à saint gilles à prendre mais
l'argent n'est pas tout quand même vous
savez pourquoi ce combat avec lui mais
que tu connais chaque année absolument
pas que ce soit près de chaque instant
bien sûr vous saviez déjà comme elle
avait su résidence et les veilleurs du
l'accent depuis un jeu le plus rapide à
6 ans je ne roule que je le prenne part
aux actions et donc c'est rigolo de
s'embrasser ne lui est pas prêt on se
fait pourtant de quoi aussi bien trempé
[Musique]
le père de soi quatre journalistes un
journaliste qui ont provoqué que tu me
plais bien tous les deux je tiens à te
le dire
m cacophonie fonctionne bien c'est que
c'est une surprise énorme je vais dit
l'autre jour je lui ai téléphoné jeudi
un grand compliment
oui j'ai dit gérald je ne suis pas je
n'ai pas fait fortune dans des
compléments jeudi gérard
cette année il ya eu deux événements
vocaux du carla bruni et toi c'est sympa
c'est vrai je le sens je le prends une
super bonne voie et voilà tu enlèves son
alliance la non non pas du tout au
contraire c'est vous nuire avait il un
petit coup là un petit coup de fil il
avait passé le week-end à deauville à
penser à l'olympia qu'est-ce qui se
passe woodcliff lake en plus au mois de
mai même l'attention faut répéter et
tours de circuit cinq ans cadre à ben
oui c'est pas la salle des fêtes je
boitais temps mois de mai mais parce que
là parce que des gens ont fait ce qui ce
qui nous plaît au mois de mai elle avait
la classe s'est plaint le rythme là
c'est une corruption qui n'a pas démarré
savoir il fait pas démarrer léger en
roue libre
on va à la vôtre mes enfants ils
viennent d'abord à nous santé pour faire
chanter bonheur sont et bonus est
choquant réponse non contact à chaleur
c'est le mec a fait american beauty
quelle pièce non cinq filles et cinq
femmes avec la même robe
et c'est une pièce qu'il a écrit en fait
avancé xvi thunder et american beauty
c'est lui qui a fait six feet under way
tu regardes pas ça six feet under
c'est des séries américaines et la pièce
c'est quoi céder dans une pièce en
dehors d'allah c'est ça ça fait un peu
cuisine et dépendance plutôt que d'être
au mariage se retrouve dans une pièce à
côté et elles ont toutes une relation
super compliqué et à l'amour et au
mariage sont demoiselle d'honneur elles
sont toutes habillées pareil c'est pour
ça
et elles ont toutes des raisons de ne
pas supporter ce mariage est pas
supporté le maillage pas
on a limité en général il ya un mec
arrive à la fin il ya makan à la fin
vous tombez amoureux du mec
et ouais et en fait c'est une scène de
séduction qui dura patron à peu près 30
20 minutes et qui est conçu vraiment
comme une suite de contrats quoi on
n'arrête pas de dire oui malheur à temps
ou mais enfin il ya tellement de
d'obstacles de résistance avant de
penser qu'on va pouvoir peut-être
s'embrasser que ça devient finalement
leur mois tension labour wen est d'une
série de contrats qu'ils n'aillent
romantique du tout je trie critique chez
gt américaine sévèrement ouais c'est
critique mais enfin dans cette pièce là
n'est pas aussi critique que peut l'être
finalement certains sauf que ça se passe
dans le sud des états unis est le côté
un peu tennessee williams voit des corps
très chargé une façon presse dans votre
visage et les choses un peu comme un
spectacle chaque fois plutôt que comme
une chose très spontané et ses
personnages qui étouffe là dedans
alors oui ça ça la critique mais le
reste c'est une comédie en fait les
consignes comédie c'est fait pour rire
et c'est moins acerbe presque s'excuser
de l'atelier non moi je viens tu sait
j'adore cet endroit - oui il a un tout
petit défaut c'est quoi ton n'est pas
très isolée dans le théâtre il y avait
un commissariat dans la côte et quand la
police sortait on entend des dents on
est inscrit dans la salle et long terme
impôts
et alors vous savez que berlin a fait un
livre sur jean paul ii qui est la bio
définitif de jeux comptines et de kato c
était ça veut dire qu'ils veulent un
américain et une vidéo de jean paul ii
c'est ça mon bois qui s'apprécient qui
s'appelait weigl qui a fait le centre 98
et le monde pensait que c'était elle
team quoi et en fait pas du tout mais
non mais parce qu'en 98 tout le monde
disait que le pape allait mourir
ouais et du gris au lieu de mourir il a
fait des tas de trucs qu'il a fait le
jubilé de l'an 2000 il à la repentance
il a fait le voyage de jérusalem il en a
fait des trucs depuis et le livre de
weigl pour bon qu'il soit évidemment ne
suffit plus que moi je me suis mis à la
tâche et pendant quatre ans j'en ai fait
un autre
quand même page il y en a beaucoup ainsi
sans 660
mais alors c'est quoi le secoue le scoop
je suis pas c'est pas un scoop mais
l'histoire en tout cas c'est l'histoire
exactement inverse de celle que michel
serrault raconter tout à l'heure c'est à
dire l'histoire de quelqu'un qui
comédiens qui hésite entre être comédien
et prêtres et qui lui en revanche choisi
la prêtresse et bien tu savais ça le
bout j'ai entendu raconte tellement d
histoire il devait être comédien jean
paul ii il l'a été
karol wojtyla et et que tu as été
comédien pendant dix ans il a fait dix
ans lauréate mais bien sûr que si mais
bien sûr que si la plupart mais la
plupart des papous ont été comédien non
justement
la plupart des papes sont sont nés dans
des familles kato un trait au petit
séminaire à 15 ans grand séminaire prête
et c'est celui là pas du tout puisque il
a choisi le séminaire il avait déjà 21
ans passés c'est ce qu'on appelle chez
nous une vocation cargaison tardive mais
entre l'agencé de 12 ans au lycée au
collège
jusqu'au delà de du séminaire qui
jusqu'en 45 karol wojtyla est d'abord un
acteur et pendant la guerre
tout le monde lui disait alors toi tu
vas être prêtre avec la fois que tu as
on te connaît et caetera et lui répond
très clairement moins prête sûrement pas
j'aurai un rôle après la guerre au
théâtre sovath qui à cracovie et donc
c'est un peu le destin inverse de celui
de michel d'ailleurs il a écrit deux
pièces de théâtre
ils ont finalement aussi on peut le
mettre sur la liste avec reagan et
schwarzenegger 1 voilà il ya quelque
chose qui doit à un règlement rapide
crochet tous ces métiers là j'aimerais
parce que c'est un showman en fer ou en
face au néant c'est vrai qu'il a fait
des trucs peut-être de là que ça vient
je sais pas c'est un blasphème
vous l'avez rencontré le pape oui mais
vrai comme ça parce que michel excuse
moi mais tu connais l'histoire
mais aujourd'hui en italie sur raconte
sa vie à zéro
un jour tu es en italie un producteur
qui dit si vous voulez je peux vous
faire rencontrer le pape tu la connais
l'histoire
alors il dit est génial je vais
rencontrer le pape et où michael
williams allemande occupe de tout comme
tous les producteurs italiens évidemment
moi j'aime en occupe de tout et puis
finalement que tu t'es acheté un costard
tu étais préparé tu t'es fait à l'idée
que j'avais rencontré le pape comme ça
en tête à tête et quand est arrivé
yacine audience publique les 6000
personnes
il maintenait retenu une chaise alors
question comme je couds bernard dans ce
bouquin
comme scoop comme scotché qu'est-ce
qu'on l'a par exemple déjà j'apprends
neige s'est coincé des femmes non il
n'est bien sûr que oui mais bel et bien
sur la lune ne l'était pas il a eu des
femmes non non il tapait pas de femme ni
un bon vieux temps qu il était comédien
se taper des femmes quand voilà un jeune
homme qui est un passionné de théâtre et
qui passe sa vie dans des répétitions
avec des jeunes filles de son âge en
effet et notamment une qui est une
remarquable comédienne que je suis allé
voir à cracovie pour lui faire raconter
toute cette histoire qui s'appellera li
na qui est d'ailleurs une femme très
belle comédienne en effet connu en
pologne et avec laquelle il a passé des
soirées des week-ends des semaines à
travailler
au théâtre il aujourd'hui on dirait il
sortait avec elle
mais attention jeu mais attention même
avant d'être en tout bien tout honneur
et l'engagement on faisait pas non mais
avant d'être prêt j'avais connu des fins
bon pas de soi ça veut dire connaître
des gens tout simplement non jeûneurs
génération non je sais pierre paquin
était plus vertueux
il y avait de tels tabou que comme je
faisais pas j'aimerais non non moi
j'étais à la recherche d'un absolu et
elle pour qu'un nom aucun homme aucune
femme ne pouvait donner de satisfaire
attendait ce que j'ai tendance à nous
dire vous c'est qu'avant d'être prête
vous êtes vous avez pas non et jean paul
ii non non plus pour ce que j'en sais
pour ce qu'il en a dit et pour ce
témoignage de sa petite amie s'était
impulsion alors n'hésitez pas dans les
moeurs c'est à l'époque c'est vrai que
c'était aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui fait du théâtre jusqu'à
l'âge de 21 2 ans j'imagine pas les
foules avec moi mais à l'époque on est
on est dans la danse dans la pologne
très 4 me qui non mais c'est vrai je
crois que toi tu as été dépêchés à l'âge
de 7 ans et non dans ce je n'étais pas
prêt ni pape
non mais je venais ça me paraît bizarre
ces types n'ai jamais eu de relations
sexuelles parce que pour renoncer à
quelque chose il faut le connaître mais
le raisonnement ne tenait pas à l'époque
mais alors il se branler tous ces types
là il est vrai que ce pape là qui venait
d'un milieu et d'un pays où on savait de
quoi on parle et quand on parlait de
l'antisémitisme dans les années 38 39
ans cologne on savait et lui se voit il
avait des amis juifs des copines juive
il
il jouait au théâtre avec des amis juifs
qui subissaient cet antisémitisme et il
a connu ça dans sa chair dans ses
amitiés et ça n'est pas totalement
étonnant qu'il se soit lancé dans cette
extraordinaire entreprise de repentance
et de réconciliation entre les juifs et
les chrétiens
l'image qu'on gardera de lui
incontestablement c'est l'image du mur
des lamentations de jeu
monsieur 4 6 1 en deux en train de
déposer sa prière dans le mur des
lamentations je crois en effet que c'est
ce qui restera certainement de lui oui
je viens viens on va être regardé la
télé non bien en jambes d'avoir wii
vient bien michel mais quoi mais écoutez
je me suis prouvé l'année
je fais beaucoup jambières de regarde
jamais fait quoi toi c'est l'énorme
travail quand il est là en même temps
mais non mais enfin j'ai fait la
converse très bientôt et je vous
donnerai une cassette où les oies oui
exactement mais m'a par exemple mon
épouse elle est formidable
moi je les ai vus fonctionnement parce
que j'ai trouvé c'est sur tf1
elle n'a pas voulu voir parce qu'on
pouvait le cinéma la technique le père
meilleur sur un grand écran
elle veut le voir à la télévision dans
les normes du petit écran n'a aucun l'on
regarde sur joueurs wii ouais bah oui
oui quel est votre petit fils au regard
de son surnom oui sûrement
j'ai bien aimé la d'avoir trois
générations
c'est michel blanc maintenant mieux en
mieux
non c'est vrai que ce terrible de soi
non pas que je lance aujourd'hui julien
que j'ai fait un film au mode où j'ai
été le voir aujourd'hui je sais même pas
quoi en penser aux moyens mais certains
moments c'est fini l'émotion c'est sur
le moment de tournage après grand bien
ce qui compte c'est la vie des autres ce
qu'ils ressentent
est ce qu'on voit au théâtre
je pense que des acteurs de cinéma c'est
bien se regarder les acteurs de cinéma
au théâtre tu peux pas te regarder
maintenant tout ça a commencé comme dans
la vie ça c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique fini on laisse tomber des
gîtes qui peut y avoir sur une heure et
demie
c'est vachement sale goût de la rosa
mais c'est superbe c'est super c'est un
goût de la rose c'est marrant c'est tout
et parfumée avec un petit couteau ça
vous plairait on se connait pas en fait
c'est moi je vous ai jamais interviewé
vous avez bien de la chance et dont je
ne connais rien de votre vie privée
évidemment aux habitudes sexuelles
visage suite
heureusement dans les lits sont pas tous
comme le pape quand même y'a quand même
un côté monitor mais parce que moi je
trouve qu'à un moment la compassion doit
amener à beaucoup plus de de tolérance
avec les gens voilà temps je pense que
chargé de donner là et je sais bien oui
non gérés nous ont fait pape comédie
voilà lui dit des trucs qui nous ont
fait le contraire donc ça prouve que
cette affaire on est obligé de sa range
son père comme l'euthanasie si non alors
barresi avant le cas nazis tu le sais
bien non maintenant la tire et vous
crachez malade dans une famille on
disait e toile toubib il dit c'est bon
tu vois l'euthanasie c'est moi je trouve
ça un problème très grave
vous ne vous en parler comme ça en
passant de la contraception à
l'euthanasie
il ya un lien c'est un problème de la
vie enfin thiam ligne de clivage entre
les croyants et non croyants
le croyait c'est ce que j'ai dit à m
c'est sûr avec une femme qui
représentait la dignité pour mourir et
jaune très bonnes intentions mais le
clivage est là si vous êtes croyant vous
pensez que la ville vient de dieu n'est
pas m si vous n'êtes pas très croyants
ou mal croyant peu croyants ben vous
pensez que vous êtes maître de la vie et
voilà qu'en dépit de charité au cenou
parfois oui mais ce qui m'embête c'est
que on peut pas commencer par le plus
grave alors les autres filles c'est la
rolls abord l'euthanasie et cetera
ils sont pas capables d'aider le copain
d'à côté alors là ça mais ça m'emmerde
je lui dis franchement commençons par
était au bea va de la religion et puis
du christianisme
et puis quand on sera sur le net les
deux morts les uns et les autres on
verra ce qu'on a à faire
alors ça ça m'emmerde je le dis
franchement alors là alors l'heure
n'était pas ça y va
je ne sais ce que je fais et ce que
j'aurai un côté je n'aurais pas est-ce
que je me fais matches 1 est-ce que tout
est vraiment [ __ ] tout ça sortait un
peu c'est comme le gadin bois les
couteliers des choses qui me révolte qui
me révolte gentiment n'est ce pas il dit
moi je donne je donne je donne je donne
aux gens quand je peux je donne je lui
ai alors des amis des amis mais michel
tu donnes ou est-ce que ça va mais je
dis mon pote toc pas
tu donnes je fais ça te regarde pas ce
ne va pas demander alors le mec et
trouver un mec dans la rue il va être
demandé
dis donc qu'est ce que tu vas faire de
mon argent enfin cadeau c'est gratuit ça
y'a pas de remboursement mais tiers et
vous savez que michel va nous faire un
cadeau merveilleux pour le soir de noël
le 24 décembre à 19h il vient dire un
compte que j'écris un conte de noël pour
les sdf de la gare de lyon mais vous
musée des arts forains
non c'est pour ça que tous les grands
débats sur l'art l'euthanasie et tout le
reste et cetera
pour moi c'est mieux quand on vient me
casser les oreilles avec ça je dis
qu'est ce que tu as fait pour la vieille
dame qui au 6e à rien alors basta
vraiment nul pas moi ah non je suis
acteur alors j'en fais un stage non mais
je ne peux pas je ne m'énerve
alors les mecs sont pas capables de bien
dit que quatre sous dd que ma bonne
vieille dame de monsieur de s'occuper
d'un enfant vous même d'un chien parce
que j'adore les animaux et cetera mais
par contre ils nous emmerdent 1 avec la
la la le savoir s'il peut la pilule ou
pas ou si je me faire piquer au moment
de ma mort basta c'est le bon dieu qui
sont le puck de ça vous sortez de vos
sous sortez de vos passions vos 4 soup
signé son retour à commencer par la
sorte ou essor les mecs calcul ou est-ce
que ça va mon programme m il met tout le
monde d'accord
la banque prédit 14 tu vas la messe moi
je
on est tellement forcé les quand j'étais
petit après je me suis un peu dégagé de
sarah changé sur tournée sur tournée
messahel s'est pas très bien produit
quand même non mais ça dépend où
moi je suis un peu déçu à chaque fois on
a abandonné le tas t on sans merci que
je lâche ta fille mais c'était un peu
réac de thierry les parents soient pas
pourquoi non mais je vois pas pourquoi
il y aurait pas de sprint et beauté le
côté moi c'était michel gilles des
ordinations de prêtres
j'ai vu des prêtres qui sont allongés
partenaires de bahreïn tels les bras en
croix comme ça c'est une beauté totale
avec les les petits-enfants là qui met
lançant les orgues et tout ça fait
partie du truc je veux dire je suis
revenu j'ai parlé au moins là vraiment
je fais une loge un peu déçu quand même
parce que chaque fois je me dis mais
pourquoi il y la prière lun pourquoi il
fait ça vient quand même eu des abus par
évolue change c'est quoi c'est le
concile si on passe du latin la même
avec toi mais pourquoi parce que d'abord
de la tête une langue occidentale je
vois pas pourquoi uniquement les
ruminants président c'est l'espéranto
des cathos pourquoi mais non vous allez
en chine on parle palatin je suis de
n'être pas non plus
au nom de quoi on va culturellement
imposer le latin l'univers entier
cellule l'église au nom de quoi
mais à allah et non celle grecque avant
on en attendre et barreau de coire
impose de croire que la vierge marie a
enfanté 100 km/h 1 et tout c'est bien
plus dur que le latin avalé un comme
histoire c'est que notre ami darmon dans
[ __ ] douce tu fais un trophée un
nouveau [ __ ] dure fait quoi le nouveau
sexuelle de vip accès aux
quinquagénaires qui a envie d'avoir un
enfant et qui va demander à sa copine de
porter son enfant donc ça va être un
ventre c'est michèle laroque
c'est michel qui est tellement que je
vais vivre la grossesse en même temps
qu'elle pratiquement cessé comme celles
commises bad
oui mais là comme leur garde d'oublier
c'est bien trop mais c'est oublier qui
écrit lol avec à lyon qu'elle maintenait
qu mekhissi keynes et la mise en scène à
notre avis rien là qui rapporte à ce qui
a été le premier [ __ ] donc c'est vrai
que t'as pas dû s'annoncer très
franchement je comédie il ya pas de
querelles dans mon film il n'y a pas de
pédophiles il ya personne s'est pas
tournée c'est quoi l'histoire de tontine
tu vois le pitch un problème c'est que
les gens qui sont artisans serruriers
menuisiers etc
pendant trente ans il travaille tous les
jours etc
et puis finalement ils n'ont jamais les
belles filles les belles voitures
l'argent est alors celui là villeray qui
en est un et il a une femme des enfants
mais il lui manque quelque chose et son
adultère à lui c'est pas simplement de
baisers leila la caissière du coin ou la
crémière du coin c'est simplement
d'avoir défi formidable des voitures
extraordinaires et conseillé par mentor
qui est michel serrault donc ils
essayent d'obtenir de sortir de sa
condition
et c'est aujourd'hui ce qui fait que 65%
après des critiques ou des gens qui ont
vu le film
m le film et 35 bon sens ne l'aiment pas
parce que il pense que eux n'arriveront
jamais à ça voyant un type qui a osé
faire les choses que fait vibrer pour
arriver à avoir ce qui ne veut ce que
nous voulons tous ceux que nous avons
tous voulu
eh bien ils sont jaloux de ce personnage
qui est quand même pas
extraordinairement intelligent pas extra
mais il a il a accepté de lutter pour
arriver à ce qu'il voulait et je pense
que ceux qui n'aiment pas le film c'est
à cause de ça de ce fait qu'ils ne
peuvent pas se réaliser ils sont là y
des charges dans leur pantalon mais qui
déchargent pas voyez ce que je suis un
peu gros mais tu fais attention à ce que
tu dis parce que ta femme sinon ce
serait je suis à table autour mais alors
donc c'est un film qui qui est celui de
tous les artisans de tous les gens qui
veulent devenir quelque chose et qui ne
peuvent pas quelquefois le devenir donc
c'est pour ça que c'est un grand sujet
et que michel lis et pathétique et
sublime technique et sublime comme le 25
mai presse iapa sceptique mais prêts à
tricher at elle fait quoi elle faire
médecin légiste qui qui qui qui voit ce
que fait vibrer parce que voudrais-tu
des gens mais il dit à l'église d aller
vite parce qu'il ya une église là
et je tue je tue tout le monde sauf les
enfants les femmes et les infirmes voyez
il a quand même il est quand même si les
prises hier ses lectrices y aura une
certaine morale voilà de ne tuer que des
salles offrent que ddd
c'est un film généreux c'est un film
voilà pour lui pour les petites gens
avec des qui rêvent des choses
magnifiques et moi le regard que je joue
il me fait pleurer un pathétique et en
plus il est ridicule mais qu'elle
voulait et on a des comme ça mais les
émissaires il est quand même il arrive
toujours à temps marqué quand même un
oui mais parce qu'il a un secret mais
comment il fait avec toi parce qu'il
avait toujours à samba bâ il me dit
écoute et voilà alors vous avez joué
saint michel même je sais pas quoi vous
faire jouer parce que je jouais toujours
pareil il commence par des monnaies vous
n'êtes pas un acteur vraiment je pense
que vous êtes mais là j'ai un 3 qu'on a
un truc que pour vous et bien tête
on va avoir un chapeau comme ça on va
voir ce que vous ferez ce que vous
voulez vous dirait un peu parce que vous
vous dressez vous changez le tête ça
pour rien et des danses et que vous avez
des dents ça m'embête
alors s'il vous plaît à rêver des motos
ou maître du noir
je vous mettais une plume dans le cul
enfin devenir visible contre eux je
crois qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs si
j'entends des choses tout bizarre sur
poiret serrault et ces vies mais c'est
pas poiret s'est passé on sait ce qui se
passait entre poire et c c'est pas moi
dans dominici c'est ce qui se passe avec
michel blanc et moore et là il ya un jeu
il ya quelque chose qui sort ça vient
pas de moi ça vient de lui et de moi le
mystère de la comédie c'est ce que les
échanges entre les gens un thé pas je ne
peux pas tu peux pas très cher pour là
où tu deviens un soliste et toujours
tout seul alors là c'est autre chose on
va voir un perroquet ou 1 mais quelle
mémoire d'anne c'est autre chose
ces mémoires dan dah
sa combi non mais ça n'existe pas ça je
joue la cage aux folles mille fois à peu
près et y avait quelqu'un qui jouait une
scène d'art tant que telle c'est très
drôle du boucher il arrivait le bouchon
des gens tu procèdes constructeurs puis
on sentait que au fur et à mesure il
donner la recette
il était un peu d'eux ils étaient un peu
teinté si j'ose dire il fait tu prends
ton temps le ton beefsteak
et puis tu grand lol plusieurs et puis
après quand tu continues quand c'est
cuit c'était ne sais pas moi l'auteur
ses jambes
c'était très drôle chaque set qui vous
qui portez magnifique mais le mec il
n'avait qu'une scène c'est à dire qu'il
n'écoutait plus du tout descente et
regarder le foot dans sa télé à un
vaisseau vert s'est désolé et puis il
faut l'équipe
il me coupais c'est à dire j'avais même
pas le temps de respirer georges edel il
n'écoutait pas ce que je disais et un
jour parce que je suis pas méchante et
sa maman sont au bout d'un moment quand
je sens bien une bonne scène
quelle image ou et ça me fait chier
quand même alors je dis je lui dis donc
en continuant de jouer dans le
personnage judith coteaux c'est pas
grave tu parles trop vite devant les
gens ouais devant les autres
les opales je faisais avec un tel culot
en jouant le personnage ce jour c'est
pas des photos fait chier et cetera non
je dis tu parles tu parles trop vite
jure ça maintenant tu me regardes tu me
regardes quand je te pose la question tu
respires et écoute
et puis tu me réponds mais c'est pas
grave cote puisque je jouais ne sait pas
pour l'heure on va le refaire
on la refait hossein et bien j'avais un
tel culot ça dépasse mes intentions
les gens se sont aperçus de rien ils ont
cru que j'étais dans la pièce
ja oui comment tu va la jouer le
personnage de [ __ ] dure je sais pas si
je peux pas lâcher comme ça tu veux pas
comme ça mais tu peux pas le faire comme
ça
aujourd'hui tu fais plus que non je
commençais aujourd'hui de passer de
l'eau mottet comme tu le faisais dans la
cage aux folles
oui ça il ya 25 ans l'a parfois c'était
lille et cp ça n'existe plus c'est fini
nous on a connu ça parce que dans les
cabarets on a connu un tas de gens de
l'antiquaire que c'est quelque chose
antiquaires qui en fait la cage aux
folles ça vient du sketch de
l'antiquaire absolument
mais maintenant maintenant les
personnages qu'on nous ait n'existe plus
il y avait des références forcément avec
je suis proche et tonton tu as connu
tout ce temps
c'était formidable c'est michou et alors
mais c'était très troublant parce que
j'en avais beaucoup de visites de gens
qui venaient dans les loges et au départ
on avait été je veux dire tous les homos
de paris qu'il y avait des copains là
dedans il était contre le penser qu'ils
vont se foutent de nous et vont se
[ __ ] de zéro il ya plein de mecs qui
venait de voir en disant il faut pas le
faire il faut pas seulement mais des
gens qui nous parlaient plus des copains
et puis au fur et à mesure qu'ils ont
ils ont vu ce qui se passait c'est que
c'est à dire que c'était il trouve pas
ça ridicule et moi j'ai eu dans ma loge
des gens qui faisaient une soirée
et quand il se met en route et quand il
se prostituer téhéran a encore mis en
bonne femme qu'avec ton texte on
s'affaire à ces thèmes et france et de
l'allemagne
tu sais quel concept pas par exemple
c'est que en italie puisqu'il y avait
bien 10 à l'humain à ses succès et bien
le succès s'est pas fait sur l'énormité
la droguerie mais sur l'émotion ouais et
les gens pleuraient peut-être oui mais
toi qu'il faisait très comme ça aussi
mais c'était l'auto dérision oui n'ont
pu y avait renoncé on était tous dedans
c'était c'était la situation impossible
à vivre et k1 dames export de
personnages on était le mec qui dit bon
on va recevoir le fils mais il faut tout
mettre en bonheur parce qu'on veut parra
va pas dire qu'on est alors l'outil dit
ben je peux aussi au mahb rien comme un
homme comme il me sert veston mégarde et
des chaussettes roses donc pas des trucs
comme ça
et alors c'était pathétique c'est et
c'était vrai c'était humain mais tu sais
que même quand je fais le clown au
cirque 1 il ya des moments de vérité qui
y sont payants faut pas tricher est
vraiment quand je dis on blague à un
jeune comédien ce que tient bien voir ce
qu'il s'y albin michel dans le film
d'avoir gerra revient et rennes sud est
vachement bien ouais tu veux pas devoir
je comprends pas
venez avec nous on va les voir fini de
vous faire mal et voilà c'est pas vrai
ce que venus des deux côtés mais je sais
patricia là c'est ça qui est merveilleux
chez vous la chambre est vrai mais chef
allait alors vous savez que j'ai perdu
mon frère
oui le père 90 110 j'étais un
enterrement mais alors convaincu on voit
que michel gourinchas niche mais c'est
comme ça que je pense que t'as foutu
grands singes vêtus de conneries ce
dernier pas si ce n'est pas le nom du
prophète il n'est pas sûr qu'il faut que
j'entre à paris c'est la fin de la
première partie
je puis cris qu'elle projette sur le
label bouger pour ne pas la trouver les
sous
bonjour vous avez vu nier quand même à
michel les biens michel j'avais deux
orphelins qu'est ce que michel ne s'est
pas l'acteur nous interne et oui non
c'est un acteur dans ma part j'y suis là
qui coûtent pas ce qui suit dans votre
tour viendra
une différence entre ces différents on
voit ce héros puis des hôtes à côté on
dirait des béni dire du mal mais c'est
pas la même chose mais vous triomphez
date d'en regarder le sérieux certains
français
elle vient de chez vous banlieue 38 12
janvier ne prendre qu'un vide pour tout
le monde clovis
j'essaie en pâture
[Musique]
on était d'accord avec la thèse de du
film là que c'est les services secrets
oui si bons souhaits aux estimations
ouais mais moi j'ai fait un rêve et
mondiale s'était bloqué nos marchés
s'améliorent
je dis que ce afin dé mignot bon plus
que star académie du prof
je sais pas sûr je connais pas bien les
scores des tubes boire un coup avant
parti renonce à roanne on m'écoute c'est
gentil de nous avoir reçu et je suis
très heureux très variés puisque les
c'est pas ta femme
mais alors heureusement peut-être ses
toiles et moi je suis marié fidèle mais
monsieur vous plaisir
m
au revoir et ses saveurs à moi encore
l'occasion de vous retrouver j'irai
peut-être voir la pièce
dès que j'aurai envie d'aller re verra
quand on ira dîner chez fogiel amuse toi
bien
la peine mon plaisir vous avez vu tout à
bientôt alors bon
non merci ça dit merci au revoir
chez elle on s'appelle pour les
audiences de deux minutes chic et voilà
38 à lui quand tu évalues thérèse vegas
je suis allé à las vegas quand il ya une
dizaine de jours j'ai vécu un rêve je
suis allé chanter ou césar palace où a
vécu mon idole c'est m j'ai chanté dans
un show de céline dion et qu'aznavour
avec salvador avec avec pagny avec garou
avec plein de gens comme ça et coleman
n'a pas osé chanter fly me to the moon 2
ces retouches alizés centré sa touche
apple était resté quand même temps les
mégane semaine c'est une semaine au
césar palace dans cette ville de tuco
nevegal avoir envie c'est une ville de
ouf
tu connais écoute ce il faut il faut y
aller une fois quoi c'est envie de rire
tu envie de pleurer en même temps c'est
kitsch c'est tu as vu la tour eiffel et
tout ça maintenant j'ai pas vu depuis
que ça a été transformée avec des
imitations de paris des imitations de
violences sexuelles et las vegas il ya
un vieux vegas à l'époque du centre à
l'époque du stardust part ça tu as le
plus exister non maintenant ils ont fait
ils ont fait paris ans sur 200 mètres
carrés ils ont fait pareil barils ils
ont construit une tour eiffel de 70
mètres qui est hôte qui est vraiment
c'est la tour eiffel c'est très
troublant je regarde plus maintenant là
la vraie normalement tu vas y mon nickel
hull le plaisir de cette tour eiffel
dans les pieds de la tour eiffel ils ont
mis la la gare d'orsay modèles réduits
mais gare d'orsay
j'ai un truc aux états unis moi quand
j'étais à l'escrimé plus surpris c'est
ce qu'ils appellent les roadside
attractions c'est-à-dire de chaque côté
de l'autoroute ya les bretelles et tu
vas dans des endroits qui sont des
attractions
il y avait un truc était génial c'est un
endroit ça m'a marqué pour la vie
c'était noël toute l'année c'est que
sans dire comme concept qui est arrivé
là-bas n'importe quel jour le 7 juillet
il y avait le père noël qui venait
c'était noël comme tous les soirs il
faisait noir elle s'était j'adore sur
dix ont une vraie fantaisie mais
[Musique]
ouais
le
[Musique]
et
les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la neige
je te laisse la maison
je laisse les autres charges
merci
aussi dans ses missions
et pas de mazouna ici avait fait quand
même
c'est tombé sur un type
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu